- I spent a whole lifetime building this.
And as long as I'm in charge,
nobody's going to knock it down.
They are cowards, that's
what they are, cowards.
They switched the lights off.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
the first prime minister
of Singapore, Lee Kuan Yew,
and my take on his top
ten rules to success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
you might win a prize, as well.
And also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(vibrant intro music)
- I am quite determined.
I may not be able to do it this way,
but don't believe I've given up.
I will think of some
other way to get there.
I think it's necessary
because if you lack that determination,
then you're not going to achieve.
You will not be able to deliver.
I am able to
get ideas across to people in simple ways
and persuade them to my point of view,
if not the first time, then the second,
the third, the fourth time.
I don't give up.
Eventually I swing them around.
Deng Xiaoping is a great man.
He fought a great revolution.
He saw
the product of that revolution turn sour.
He was fortunate to live long enough
and he had the courage to
say, "No, we change course."
"Let's learn.
"Let's stop trying
"to do everything by ourselves."
So they started importing
and buying Boeing 707s.
So they bought Tridents
instead of trying to
manufacture their own aircraft.
Eventually they will,
but it will take two,
maybe three generations.
That's how we succeeded
because we have open minds,
common sense.
A lot of analysis, careful
weighing of the odds,
make a firm decision,
monitor it, implement it,
modify, as it goes wrong.
Abandon if it is no good.
Life is what you make of it.
You're dealt a pack of cards,
your DNA is fixed by your
mother and your father.
And even your siblings, but
you will get different parts
of parcels of the DNA.
Your job is to make the best
of the cards that they handed out to you.
What can you do well,
what can you not do well,
what are you worst at?
If you ask me to make
my living as a artist,
I'll starve
because I just can't draw.
It wasn't in my father or my mother
or my great-grandfather's
or grandmother's.
But if you ask me
to do a mathematical question
or to argue a point out, I get by.
That's the cards I was handed out
and I make use of them.
Don't try and do something
you are not favored by nature to do.
I can tell you that when
I met the SIA pilots,
I didn't meet them on TV,
I met them face-to-face,
five feet across the
table, so they can see me
and see whether I'm still vigorous,
able to campaign and take them on,
whether it's worth taking me on.
And I offered them two choices.
Either you argue, you
stop this intimidation,
which is what it was,
bringing SIA right down,
disrupting services,
ruining its reputation.
Millions of dollars worth
of advertisements and sales
ruined within a matter of two weeks.
I gave them a choice.
Continue this
and I will,
by every means at my disposal, teach you
and get the people of Singapore,
help me teach you a
lesson you won't forget.
And I'm prepared to start all over again.
Or stop it, get back to
work, restore discipline,
then argue your case.
Took them 65 minutes
and they decided, okay,
it isn't worth the fight.
Why?
Because they know they'll lose.
They know that I'm prepared
to drown the airline
and they know that I can
get the airline going again
without them.
And let there be no mistakes about this.
Whoever governs Singapore
must have that iron in him
or give it up.
This is not a game of cards.
This is your life and mine.
I spent a whole lifetime building this.
And as long as I'm in charge,
nobody's going to knock it down.
We have so much at stake.
We have gone so far to secure the country.
I say rally around and
keep these evil forces--
You see, they are so
ashamed of themselves,
they have switched the light off.
Look at that.
They are cowards, that's
what they are, cowards.
They switched the lights off.
(applause)
Look at that.
Are these men who are going to lead you
to peace and prosperity
or to ruination and position?
(applause)
Look at that
God knows what they're doing in the dark.
(applause)
And I say this,
they succeed on the basis of intimidation.
And I say
that they make the error that
we are easily intimidated,
then they have a lot to be sorry for
because you know we have so much at stake,
we can't afford to be intimidated.
- Why do you have so
little faith in the ability
of your people, so well-educated,
to make intelligent
judgements on diversity
of ideas on competing news?
- I have been in office for now 29 years.
I've won seven general elections
since my first in 1959.
I think that qualifies me
at least to be able to say
that I do know Singapore
better than the questioner.
Your father and grandfather's generation
lived a hard life.
Very few people had homes of their own.
In Chinatown,
you have cubicles, eight
or ten people in the room
sharing four bunks
because they do shift work, save money.
If you lived in those
conditions and you get a flat,
one room, which is what we started with,
communal bathroom, communal kitchen,
running hot and cold, water closet.
That's from the lowest depths of the ship
to a deck with a window with
a porthole and air coming in.
And from that, to go to a three-room
or four-room or five-room flat,
you go up to the higher
levels of the ship.
And finally now, we've got
executive flats and condominiums
that means you're on a
cruise ship at the very top.
Now, I have watched my
grandchildren grow up
and they are growing up
much more comfortably
than my children.
My wife and I made sure that
they became self-reliant
and not somebody will pick
up their balls for them.
As Prime Minister, I was
given a house at Sri Temasek,
so I took them there one day to play,
and Sri Temasek's on high ground,
they're playing with a
ball, the ball rolled down.
And the butler ran
50 or 60 yards to pick up
the ball and bring it back.
My wife and I watched that and said,
"Oh no, if we stay here for five years,
"my children grow up believing
that life is like that,
"that somebody will always
pick up balls for them."
We stay at home.
And I think that's been good for them.
And that is a problem we face today.
Many of the parents who aren't
this [Inaudible: 00:14:27],
started like the people in Chinatown.
They understand what it is to be poor.
Today's children do not
understand what it is to be poor.
But, you can intellectually
and emotionally understand
if we don't make the same effort,
you go back to where you were.
We made mistakes.
We put money in [Yoo-Pock:
00:14:55], in Jurong,
second-hand machinery.
We were young then, we
were new in the game.
They sold a second-hand
machine, we didn't know.
We lost money.
We wrote it off, but we learned.
Human beings are not like computers.
You know, you can take one computer bank,
plug the terminals, and all
the data from one computer bank
can go into another.
But human beings start with fresh minds.
You get a newborn child, he grows up.
Completely blank.
Input from parents, input from
friends, input from teachers.
But no input is as vivid, as long-lasting,
as his own experience.
I'd rather strut my inner motivations,
my proclivities.
If you want me to have a go,
I would say I'm consistent.
I don't say one thing today
and another tomorrow and change again
the day after tomorrow.
It's not that I'm inflexible.
There are circumstances where
the situation is altered
and I'm prepared to say,
well, this no long applies,
but on the whole I stay consistent.
I had three journalists write
up a book on my speeches.
I asked them at the end,
"What was the dominant theme you found?"
And the three of them said,
"Consistency throughout all
of 40 years in public eye."
What I said at the beginning
throughout all that period,
the theme stayed loud and clear.
I don't mean it's simple
because you know where you stand with me
and you know what I want to do.
You see, the whole of my adult life,
I had believed in Malaysian merger
and the unity of these two territories.
You know, it's a people connected
by geography,
economics,
and ties of kinship.
Will you mind if we stop for a while?
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Amit Gupta asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know which
clip resonated the most
with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a
quick trick to Brian Tracy.
Brian, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and posting the review
on your Facebook page.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope we can take you
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- What's the most important change,
or most significant change
in your way of thinking
about the world over the last
20 years?
- That the impossible can happen.
I never thought that the Soviet Union
would improve so easily.
And I never thought that
the Chinese would abandon
the communist system
and move into the free market so readily.
It was unthinkable 20 years ago.
Both has happened, the world has changed.
- And it's not clear exactly
how it's all going to--
- No, it is not exactly
clear when it will happen.
- [Interviewer] Exactly.
- But that it will happen
now in the long-term.
50 to 100 years, yes.
- [Interviewer] And the center of gravity
is shifting to Asia.
- It must be because
the population's there.
The talent pool of 1.3 billion people,
plus the Japanese, the Koreans,
the Vietnamese, and the others,
it can match Europe and America.
But that talent pool was inert,
did not have science and technology,
did not care about science and technology.
But now, everything that you do,
Asia's doing.
I ignore polling as a
method of government.
I think that shows a
certain weakness of mind,
an inability to chart a course.
Whichever way the wind blows,
whichever way the media
encourages the people to go,
you follow.
You are not a leader.
If your message is one of despair,
then you should not be a leader.
You must give people hope,
hope of improving their condition.
There are moments, of course,
when you feel very down,
either because you're physically
down or emotionally down
or because the world has
turned adverse against you.
I think when you are in that condition,
the first thing you do is
to get a good night's sleep.
Then get a swim or chase a ball,
get the cobwebs out of your mind.
I believe, and I practice this
for all these years in politics,
that if you are not fit,
you're going to make mistakes.
Physically fit.
You must stay physically and mentally fit.
I exercise everyday.
I used to jog, swim, play golf.
Golf more for relaxation,
just to get away from the
smoky conference rooms.
And it's part of the balance you keep.
Now, I cycle, I swim, even when I travel.
And since the last 10 years or so,
I've learned to meditate
because it's one way of calming yourself.
It takes practice.
I had a doctor teach me.
He was a Buddhist.
He retired and he spends his time
helping people to meditate,
especially those with calming in lessons.
You know, to take life calmly.
And I think at the end of say,
20 minutes to half an hour,
my pulse rate can down
from 100 to about 60.
I mean, you can feel yourself subside.
I mean you still your
mind, you empty your mind.
Then when you're rested,
you resume quietly.
If you've still got the same problems,
maybe you sleep on it,
come back, look at it for a days
then decide maybe there's
a better way of solving it
or talk to some friends, get some ideas.
But if you are not in good shape,
you're going to make mistakes
and that's disastrous.